foreign
Kansas City hi Samantha how are you
I'm doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I just
um lost my husband around about
146 days ago wow he took his wife oh no
our home oh no and I
yes how old was he
uh 52. what was his name Samantha
John John
I'm so sorry man
thank you wow
you have children
yes what age
um my son is 23 he's an engineer and my
daughter is 25 she's a nurse
[Music]
are they in the area
yes we are all very close good good I'm
so sorry how long were you married
um 26 years together 27.
I can't I'm so sorry
wow how can we help darling
well
I am trying to
um
figure out if I am worthy enough to move
could carry any more
if it would help me with the guilt
and if I could afford it
I think that I can
um I just need an outside neutral person
to
walk me through it
tell me about the word worthy what do
you mean
I think any time that
someone
finds their significant other or a
family member something of that nature
um
in that fashion
that there's always guilt that you are
that you carry
with that there's a big burden to bears
and so
you start to feel extremely stuck
and you feel like if you leave the place
that you were
together that you're disrespecting
that person
and I've tried every day to
respect him I write to him
I sing to him I talk to him
and so
I'm very isolated because my
my children panic when they come here my
parents don't want to come here and I
have this really
interesting relationship with my home
but I also know that I need to leave it
to move forward with my life it's just
going to be I completely agree yeah can
I can I be super super difficult can I
be super direct with you is that okay
okay
um thing number one I don't ever want
you to ask the question am I worthy
again
got it okay answer's yes
okay okay answer number I'm going to
tell you a quick little aside
about a year ago I was cleaning out a
closet upstairs and I do this every
couple of years and there was a tweed
jacket that my granddad gave me one of
the greatest men I've ever met
and it has never fit and he passed away
a couple years ago
and I remembered him I laughed a little
bit because he had a funny thing he
always did and then I put it in the keep
pile and as I set it down I immediately
picked it back up and I held it
then I put my fist in my chest God I
don't mind him getting choked up again
and I said out loud by myself
my granddad is not in this jacket he's
right here in my chest
I need you to hear me say your husband
is not in that home
he is in your heart
and that's where he's going to be
and did that man love you
I hope so I'm gonna tell you right now
he loved you to the end of the Moon
and he probably got sideways in his own
mind and thought he was doing everybody
a favor
right
I agree
and so what I want you to hear me say is
the greatest
way to honor him
is it you go be well
and being in that home where you can't
have access to your family where you
don't have access to yourself you don't
have access to your your kids is not
helping you be whole every time you walk
down the hall
and you you say it all again you've seen
stuff that nobody should see I've been
in those homes in the middle of the
night yeah you saw it and it stamped
itself on your heart yeah I suggest if
you're my sister I would tell you to
move out of the house if you're my mom I
would tell you move out of that house
move out of that house
okay
what will it sell for
um 420 or more okay um and what what do
you owe what do you own what do you owe
on it nothing nothing okay and you live
in Kansas followed your plan okay so
Samantha you have 420 000 to go buy a
house
okay okay or if you want to rent for six
months and cry
and then buy a house oh I think I've
done enough of that well you got 100 you
only have 146 days of it so far but yeah
you're not you're not done and when you
sell this house quote the lady I'm
talking to it'll be hard right yeah if
I'm you
um emotionally spiritually financially
everything your best shot at healing and
putting this horrible tragedy in the
rear view mirror not forgetting him but
putting the thing in the rearview mirror
and living into your future not living
into your past is to not have to walk
down that Hall again and see that image
in your mind every time you walk down
the hall am I wrong right
no I would put a call I go to
ramseysolutions.com get a real estate
ELP
tell them what happened tell them what's
going on and tell them put the house on
the market by Saturday
I want you out of there
okay and I want you to tell you how's
that feel yeah when I said that yeah it
feels good feels really good I always
wanted to call you and tell you I was
debt free and
um I'm debt-free you are you are that's
now I'm calling you are and you're about
to have a whole different level of
Freedom right now and it's not going to
be
um dishonoring yeah
and life is not to run a museum
that's not your call it feels like a
museum and it feels like a grave it's
both it is it is all of the above and
it's time for you to go turn the lights
on somewhere else and live I want you to
call your kids and say hey I'm about to
go through it we're going to have some
joy and we're gonna have some help and I
want y'all with me y'all come over here
and get what you want because I'm
getting ready to shovel this stuff into
the dumpster in the back and we're
leaving yeah that's you know get a
construction dumpster out there and fill
it up but I want you to look in the
mirror and I want you to put your hand
on your chest I want you to say out loud
John is here he's not in this house he's
not in this hallway he's not in these
walls he's here in your heart and it's
time for me to go